[Música]
cuál es el objetivo o el fin de una
empresa si vamos aquí a cualquier
empresa de bilbao y preguntamos si os
pregunta a muchos de vosotros
seguramente me responderéis cosas como
vender más conseguir más beneficios
algún valiente igual dice incluso
aquello de sobrevivir y dar más
beneficios a los inversores
es decir que sobrevivir es el objetivo
de una empresa es como decir que el
objetivo del ser humano es respirar no
es algo necesario pero eso no quita que
no sea el objetivo final de nuestras
vidas
por ello
me parece muy importante distinguir que
el objetivo de la empresa tiene que ser
crear valor para los clientes y para la
sociedad y que por supuesto la
supervivencia y el dar esos beneficios
al inversor vendrá como consecuencia de
ello
hoy quería recalcar en la temática de
esta charla que las personas que las
empresas son el motor de cambio para
crear un mundo mejor mejores empresas un
mundo mejor
hace pocos años como veréis hace pocos
años terminé la universidad estudio un
grado que se llama liderazgo emprendedor
e innovación suena muy pomposo es un
poco compost pero realmente es un
empresarial es un poquito más práctico
de crear empresas y demás y después de
eso cuando termine ese proyecto de fin
de grado entre la industria de reciclaje
de plástico que es una industria como
cualquier otra el tema es que hay tuve
la oportunidad de desarrollar proyectos
de innovación proyectos tecnológicos e
incluso una spin-off que finalmente se
convierte en una empresa que tenemos
entre varios audios que somos bastante
jovencitos también y ahí nos dimos
cuenta y yo particularmente de que el
concepto que normalmente se nos dice de
la empresa está bastante anticuados o
que lo que yo por lo menos estudié en
bachiller en clase de economía era que
esta empresa
un ente y hoy en día se ha cambiado
notablemente sobre todo por cuatro
aspectos fundamentales que os voy a
decir por un lado las salidas laborales
por otro lado la actividad que realiza
la empresa cómo se organiza y el impacto
que genera si hablamos de las salidas
laborales yo me imagino a mi abuelo no
que termina de estudiar si eso entraba
en una empresa y estaba en esa empresa
trabajando hasta que cumplía los 65 o
los años que fueran y el jubilado a
felizmente hoy en día las personas
cambiamos entre 5 y 7 veces de trabajo
durante toda nuestra carrera laboral
incluso estamos como mucho 10 años en
una misma empresa por otro lado la
seguridad laboral también ha cambiado
muchísimo no hay más que mirar el kobe y
todos los serte seres y demás que ha
traído esa seguridad prácticamente
desaparecido por eso cuando la gente
habla de la jubilación de los jóvenes yo
me río
y generación yo creo que eso de la
jubilación va a ser como una utopía
vamos a algo bastante poco tangible
entonces por otro lado en segundo lugar
tenemos la parte de la actividad de la
empresa que es otra cosa que ha cambiado
mucho también cuando hablamos de la
actividad de la empresa hablamos por un
lado de los activos antes los activos
eran unos activos muy tangibles como las
máquinas que tienen la empresa las
fábricas que tienen la empresa del
edificio la tecnología eso era lo que
realmente contaba pero hoy en día se
calcula que el 65% de lo que vale una
empresa son activos intangibles como por
ejemplo el valor humano las personas el
activo de las personas y el valor de
marca es decir lo que tras lo que le
transmite la empresa lo que aporta a la
sociedad y luego por otro lado el cómo
desarrolla esa actividad dentro de su
ecosistema dentro de la naturaleza hasta
ahora se decía creamos un producto se
usa y se tira pero es inviable estamos
viendo que el planeta no puede soportar
este ritmo
entonces qué podemos hacer pues hoy en
día se están empezando a llevar las
economías regenerativas que vale
producimos usamos y luego retornamos eso
al proceso productivo y si hay algo que
haya que reciclar también que sea
pensando en que pueda volver a esas
fábricas producciones o servicios en
tercer lugar tenemos la parte de la
organización antes hablábamos del
capital humano pero antes se habla más
bien de recursos humanos esas personas
que son números que forman parte de los
turnos de 1 de mañana de tarde de noche
pero como bien diría mi padre que
trabaja mi tarea
si dijera recursos humanos tendría que
decir gestión y desarrollo del talento y
es que la gestión y desarrollo del
talento no es otra cosa que a esas
personas y sacar lo mejor de ellas para
que aporten a ese proyecto al que
llamamos empresa
por otro lado es muy importante también
que esas personas no estén dirigidas no
les manden sino lo que hagan sean
liderar las llevarlas hacia una misma
visión llevarlas hacia ese proyecto de
empresa y para ello durante mucho tiempo
nos han dicho que el dinero es la base
de todo el dinero y el tener cierto
puesto que llega un punto cuando ya
tenemos ciertas necesidades cubiertas
que buscamos mucho más allá buscamos por
un lado la autonomía ahora lo hemos
visto en tiempos de que el teletrabajo
buscamos el poder amoldar no es decir
cómo cuándo dónde hacer ese trabajo por
otro lado estamos buscando también la
maestría en aquel talento que tenemos
desarrollarla está a nuestro máximo
potencial y eso nos llena por dentro y
también el propósito el que nuestros
valores vayan unidos con los valores de
esa empresa si conseguimos eso
conseguiremos que las personas se
sientan parte de la empresa y pues es
tan importante meterlo dentro de la
estructura de organización es como si os
digo que cuando te vamos con unos amigos
con la cuadrilla no para comer lo
importante es la comida es lo importante
no es la comida como tal
lo importante es venir a hacer la compra
la persona que cocina el que está
contando los chistes el resto trabaja y
por supuesto el que no deja que ni un
solo vaso de sidra se quede vacío
todo ello cuenta todo ello es importante
y forma parte del ecosistema de la
empresa
y por supuesto en cuarto lugar queda el
impacto no nos podemos olvidar de ello
hasta en el impacto social era un
departamento de rss que decía cada año
bueno cuatro personas de traje vamos a
donar 10 mil euros a no sé qué causa y
punto
ahí se quedaba pero hoy en día nos hemos
dado cuenta de que la responsabilidad
social va mucho más allá va mucho más
allá sobre todo porque tiene que
impactar en todo lo que nos rodea en
todo lo que rodea a las sociedades
empresas luego por otro lado también
tenemos la parte del impacto
medioambiental
como he dicho antes no puede ser usar y
tirar y generar un montón de residuos
huella de co2 huella hídrica tenemos que
ir mucho más allá y trabajar la economía
circular en las empresas como parte de
nuestro impacto en tercer lugar está muy
bien pensar en crear el menor impacto
posible pero en realidad tras pintar que
un impacto positivo porque por un lado
está el accionista que es el accionista
económico al que le debemos unos
dividendos y por otro lado tenemos a la
activista social que son las personas
que nos rodean los trabajadores los
compañeros la ciudad del pueblo todo eso
también son accionista y hay que
rendirle cuentas sino imaginaos el yo
que se puede organizar
es decir a través de estos cuatro
ejemplos y os quería mostrar que las
empresas han cambiado radicalmente y que
las empresas como se decía antes son un
motor de cambio pero también depende de
hasta donde queramos llevarlas nosotras
que queramos hacer nosotras para
aportarles
igual os engañan un poquito os he dicho
que las empresas son el motor de cambio
pero en realidad que son las empresas
que son las organizaciones sino personas
que están organizándose personas que
comparten un propósito para crear algo
más por lo que lo correcto sería decir
que las empresas son herramientas y que
las personas son el motor de cambio cada
uno de nosotros tenemos el poder de a
través de la comunicación a través de la
educación a través de todo lo que nos
rodea hacer pequeños grandes cambios y
todo eso también por supuesto lo podemos
hacer a través de la empresa a través de
nuestro trabajo voy a contar una
historia que a mí siempre me encanta
ponerlo como ejemplo que es el caso de
una niña en un pueblo que vio como había
tres hombres haciendo una obra entonces
acercó al primero de los hombres que
está un poco malhumorado
pues no ves niña que estoy poniendo
piedras
y fue donde el segundo hombre se acercó
a un este segundo hombre que está así
como pichincha como si la vida pasar el
aire pasa por él y nada más
y el hambre jornada
así como sin energía sobreviviendo
vaya con curiosidad es que los niños
tiene mucha curiosidad y de preguntarnos
no se cansan así que se ha acercado en
el tercer obrero y pronto perdone usted
qué hace con una sonrisa en la cara dijo
mira niña estoy construyendo la catedral
del pueblo
seguro que conocéis a personas como el
primer ejemplo a esos obreros las
personas que están desencantados con su
vida con el universo y como si todo se
fuera pipe luego están las personas que
que todo les da igual y luego esas
personas que brillan con luz propia esas
personas que nos transmiten tanto que
son como el tercer obrero que ven no que
las cosas sean simplemente una pequeña
actividad sino que todo aporte al
conjunto y es que tenemos que conseguir
que las empresas y las personas que
trabajan en las empresas sean como ese
tercero obrero que se sientan parte de
un todo mucho más grande
y es que están muy empresas que las
empresas cambian el mundo pero también
es importante pasarlo en que nosotros
mismos cambiemos había una vez un hombre
se cuenta que quería cambiar el mundo
entonces en la política y dijo bueno yo
aquí voy a cambiar el país a base de
política y sería un poco por vencido
dijo bueno pues voy a intentarlo siendo
político en el pueblo
y un fracaso total todo el día de riña
se dijo bueno por lo menos mi familia la
voy a cambiar me voy a meter aquí con la
familia bueno casi le cuesta el divorcio
y finalmente se dio cuenta de que si
realmente él se hubiera cambiado del
primero y así hubiera inspirado a su
familia a sus hijos a su mujer a cambiar
luego su familia hubiera inspirado a
todo el pueblo ese pueblo a su vez
hubiera inspirado a las ciudades al país
y ese país hubiera logrado un cambio en
el mundo
por eso es tan importante y yo quiero
recalcar y quiero que os queréis con eso
de esta charla quiero importante es
cambiar por dentro una vez que nosotros
cambiamos por dentro somos capaces de
influenciar y cambiar a todo lo que nos
rodea
y es que la el tema de la charla era
mejores empresas un mundo mejor pero yo
creo que deberíamos decir mejores
personas mejores empresas mejores
empresas un mundo mejor muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
d
no
[Música]